watching myself i think has been a great
thing really it's been very hard yes i i
don't think it should be i don't know
how sustainable i think you make
good decisions for yourself
are you making are you contemplating are
you uh are you
doing it for yourself or do you think
this is because when we're in this
business
i was i was i'm all over the place but
ultimately you want to garner an
audience right and sometimes we are so
critical of ourselves that we'll cut out
something that maybe the audience will
no no no i i uh my
i watch it as somebody who uh can't
control me i'm watching as somebody
who's controlling the podcast i'm trying
to make what's best for the podcast but
at the beginning of my career the way i
started if you go look at old videos i
was just terrified and that terror was
my whole act i didn't have an act
hilarious
that's not the point the point is i was
going okay okay because i couldn't think
of what to say and i'm going what what
because i didn't understand what they
were laughing at and i carried rubber
gloves because i didn't i i
in case i had to go to a a public
restroom like you just did i would have
a rubber glove with me and out of
nothing to do i pulled it over my head
and blew it up it's not like something
where i said you know tonight i'm going
to blow a rubber glove up on my head so
if i would watch it
in my mind
this was just me being terrified and it
was embarrassing but people were
responding to it so i left oh you're
looking at it wrong no he's he's that's
his truth that's that's how he felt but
he's wrong well what he did was
hilarious
it was entertainment but i find that
about you the the point he's making is
that that there are multiple
perspectives and yes you're saying you
see that in retrospect he's saying i was
terrified i was this i know in the
moment i was terrified no but i'm saying
when you when you're analyzing what you
did that's what he's trying to say to me
no but what i'm saying is that he
understood what he did was funny
um
i get it i understand what you're saying
i find you like i'm looking back i feel
that i hope you don't take this
negatively but i feel like you're a
young me um i don't take that negatively
because i i like myself
yeah seeing
um
uh
i've you know
i've just met you but seeing you and
there aren't many people
um
i guess now there are some more with
podcasts but that are publicly talking
about that kind of stuff and uh i take
it as a compliment
when somebody is able to uh have their
challenges and
it's it's it becomes part of the
identity i don't think it's something we
should rely on necessarily i don't want
to be known as the guy who blah blah but
it is
i like basketball i don't like to touch
things i'm jewish i have a lot of
different things and this is one of them
and i don't edit that out and i don't
edit around it um
because the key to
connecting with an audience no matter
what you're doing is authenticity they
have to believe it and either you've got
to be a really good actor or you've got
to be authentic you know you got to be
real you could in your case you're
probably both
you know a really good actor and and
authentic right
but
to overthink how people are going to
perceive something you do or how you
show up or what happens in the 10
minutes is too much hear me on this okay
there's a difference between words
i'm sorry you said hear me
there's a difference between worrying
about how other people's pers other
people
other people perceive you other people
perceive me speaking from my
uh perspective
versus seeing myself on camera and then
gaining perspective of like oh like i
didn't see myself that way yet and being
able to see myself on camera and seeing
some of the things i'm doing and not
liking it maybe i'm judging maybe i'm
just trying to grow and i truly don't
know the difference
but like there are times
i'll give you an example uh i watch
myself um
in a moment i'm talking about something
that i don't like what we're talking
about i i don't know if you could relate
to this but you change the subject and i
do it all the time and i watch myself do
that and i get mad at myself as an
audience member watching some guy even
though that guy is me let the other
person say the thought what was he gonna
get to in the moment i don't know so i
have now
i'm trying to add on to my tools if i'm
distracted or i don't like what the
person's saying or something give it at
least another 15 seconds
see where it goes
as long
all right
i i think that it's objective you know
like maybe the fact that you're not
listening or you interrupt or you don't
pay attention or you're not catching on
or you're doing something might
possibly everything you're saying makes
sense on paper
but then if you're
just holding for another 15 seconds
because you think that looks better or
it looks like you're not cutting people
off or it makes you look more interested
then you lose some of the authenticity
because then you become it becomes
mechanical rather than natural and here
we're all natural except for the fluids
going into my body
right now
eight seconds ago while you were telling
me what you're telling me i know what
you're talking about but i didn't cut
you off to stop you to explain no no
that's not what i meant i let you finish
thank you you're welcome i wrote a poem
go ahead
i never used a bidet before until i did
and then when i flushed it it sprayed my
face
i will never use one again i said but
then i did
because i wanted to wash my face
go ahead finish your thought
you let him finish yeah that's what i'm
talking about yeah sometimes well it was
a [ __ ] poem
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna change and
and i'm gonna ask you a question go
ahead about laughing at people all right
what happens when somebody tells you a
joke right and never happens and you
don't
think it's funny
no disrespect watch it let me watch you
when it's funny
i don't laugh to be honest with you i
don't get anyone you're lying i'm lying
because people come up no people come up
to him all the time on the street
strangers will come up and it's either
deal or no deal or ask if they cut out
audition for agt in front of him or
they'll tell him a joke oh that's the
best
whenever they tell a joke regardless of
whether or not it's funny and i'll tell
you most of the time it's not that funny
he
like pretends smiles and laughs oh to a
stranger coming up to me in the street
i'll laugh is that the question
in any situation any in any situation
where like now if you
right now i don't i don't know you that
well but i've been watching you you know
i know rick
thank you you're welcome
if you as
professionals
like if you would ask me i'm going to
open up with this in my next stand up
act or i want to do this on the podcast
do you think that that's funny or do you
think this is the way to do it i would
answer you honestly i because of this
situation that we're in right now and
how i feel about you and i respect your
work
not i respect every human being and have
empathy but some stranger who comes up
to me in the street and wants to tell me
a joke they want to make me laugh so i
feel like it's transactional yeah and
even if it's a joke i've heard a
thousand times i'm not gonna say to that
person you know i've heard this joke
stop i've heard it a million times
i feel like it's you know
the fact that you even recognize me in
this day and age when there are you know
eight million podcasts eight million
channels and you're wearing a mask and
and there's and there's games and you
know who i am and to
for me to give you a minute of your time
i feel like
i would never have guessed that at this
age i'm an old guy um you're the same
age as her
you know as my kids you know i would
yeah you are
you're 37. you're 37 yeah yeah
congratulations you know poetry has
become a book like you're 25. oh thanks
she's
37 with two kids she's old
poetry has become a huge part of my life
for me poetry has become a huge huge
part of my life i i see poetry in almost
everything and for example i got up one
morning and i was having my coffee and i
looked out the window
and and the sun was shiny and i thought
i'm gonna
and i because i was inspired by what i
saw so i ran
i ran and found some paper and a pen
and i came back to the window and took
the sip of the coffee and i looked out
and and i wrote this poem
the sun is out and it's shining
like in a situation like that right
where
where you need to acknowledge it or the
momentum shifts in a place that you
don't know where it's gonna go hold on
but he loves awkwardness i think his
sense of humor is awkwardness i live in
i feel i wake up if there's one
feeling it's not an emotion but if
there's one feeling that is overwhelming
in my life it's awkward it's a poem
he said good joke by the way i said it's
a [ __ ] poem yeah don't call his poems
jokes he doesn't like it very soon i
call anything that i enjoy a joke well
really this is a delicious joke anything
yeah because everything eats your jokes
well somebody has to
[Music]